can Donald Trump become president while
saying stuff like this and we're gonna
get him the hell up nobody's going
through my wall insulting Latinos seems
like an odd strategy when they make up
17% of the US population they're also
the fastest-growing demographic and 11
percent of eligible voters are Latino
George W Bush won those elections by
getting about 44 percent of the Latino
vote
Mitt Romney only got 27% after that
defeat the Republican Party decided it
couldn't afford to appear anti-immigrant
and anti-latino anymore and with the
growing Latino population whoever wants
to be the next president will need
around 47 percent of the Latino vote
Trump might be the leading Republican
contender so far but among Latinos he's
dead last